[Music]
on this Sunday night 100 days of War
Israel vows not to stop the
bombardment as trapped gazin face
displacement destruction and death a
Canadian delegation touches down in the
region our one-on-one with an Ontario
surgeon just back from Gaza how he got
in and why it was tough to come home
there's a certain camaraderie about
saving lives together which made me
forget about my own
safety the West's winter wo the
dangerous cold the request to conserve
power and where temperatures could still
plummet Denmark has a new king a new era
begins after a surprise
abdication global national with baren
Asser good evening and thank you for
joining us for 100 days the world has
watched The Deadly conflict between
Israel and Hamas escalate to
unprecedented Heights it's the deadliest
most destructive and longest conflict
between the two bitter enemies in
history and on this 100th day of tragedy
Israel's assault continues with new
attacks on Gaza more death and more
human suffering Israel's Relentless
offensive has resulted in large swaths
of The Enclave being raised to the
ground a growing humanitarian
catastrophe and a looming threat of a
wider regional conflict and More Than 3
months in Hamas remains intact with more
than 130 hostages still in captivity
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu vows to bring them all home
and continue his offensive until Hamas
is
crushed for the families of those held
captive there's pain and anguish and
frustration as they await word of their
loved ones Danielle Haman is in
Jerusalem tonight where thousands have
gathered for a rally and a warning some
of the details in her reporting are
disturbing Danielle Farah in what's
known as hostages Square in central Tel
Aviv Israelis gathered for 24 hours
straight praying for and demanding the
return of those still held captive by
Hamas and it wasn't just people
businesses as well as shops restaurants
and companies went on strike for a 100
minutes to Mark the day remember that
the majority of people in Israel support
their military's war against Hamas but
at the same time the families of the
hostages also believe Israel's campaign
in Gaza their actions are endangering
the lives of their loved ones we are
calling everybody who can do something
to bring them back there are still 136
hostages left in The Enclave for their
families here who spend every waking
hour trying to keep them in the
headlines they tell us that not knowing
their whereabouts their condition or
treatment is simply excruciating let's
figure this out already it's enough
let's bring them home 100 days too many
let's not get to 101 some have had Proof
of Life thanks to the hostages who have
been released but who also returned to
Israel with horrific
details one woman who'd been held by
Hamas for 51 days along with her three
children was one of the speakers on
stage today she said that they'd been
exposed to hostages whose limbs had been
amputated in captivity there are also
those who believe that their release
should come at any cost even if it means
the release of every single Palestinian
prisoner now since the only hostage
release deal in late November their
families have been given very little
hope that both sides can agree on
another deal far Danielle hjin in
Jerusalem tonight thank you Danielle
from Melbourne to Bangkok throughout
Europe to Washington DC a global day of
action for Gaza this weekend saw tens of
thousands of people taking to the
streets in major cities around the world
While others gathered to remember those
killed on October 7th and the hostages
still in
Gaza in torano hundreds got together for
a vigil in honor of those still being
held hostage by Hamas one of many such
Gatherings and also in downtown Toronto
outside the Israeli consulate Pro
Palestinian demonstrators came out to
call for a ceasefire and for more
protection for the people of
Gaza five Canadian MPS arrived in Jordan
today for a mission through the region
Israel's bombardment has led to a mass
displacement of people since the October
7th attack by Hamas nearly 24,000 people
have been killed that's according to the
Hamas run health authority and that
makes up about 1% of gaza's population
and 70% of the Dead are women and
children Israel's foreign Ministry says
at least 1200 people have died including
two civilians killed today when a
missile fired from Lebanon hit their
home in a town near the border as David
Aken reports fears are mounting about a
larger more unpredictable
conflict in Gaza it has been 100 days of
War Death destruction and displacement
tens of thousands have been forced to
flee including this woman and her
family the 100 days that passed felt as
long as whole life heaker says they were
the worst days we ever lived we feel
that we are in a nightmare that we
cannot leave we don't know what will
happen next is there something worse
than this Israel's prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu meeting with his
cabinet Sunday has brushed off calls for
a ceasefire saying Israel will keep
going until it achieves complete victory
over Hamas Israel's military though says
the next phase of its war will see
months of more targeted operations
against the movements lead leaders and
their
positions nearby in Jordan five Canadian
MPS two liberals and three new Democrats
arrived to begin a 5-day tour the group
led by Scarboro Ontario liberal MP Salma
zahid has been critical of the Trudeau
government for not doing enough to press
for a ceasefire in Gaza they will travel
from Jordan to the West Bank and on to
Jerusalem their travel is sponsored by
the Canadian nonpartisan charity the
Canadian Muslim vote the purpose is to
showcase face the daily struggles of
Palestinian refugees living in Jordan as
well as Palestinians living in East
Jerusalem and the occupied West Bank
meanwhile there continue to be signs
that the conflict is spreading on
Israel's northern border with Lebanon
for example Hezbollah militants have
engaged in sporadic attacks to show
solidarity with Hamas and on Sunday
Israeli authorities said a mother and
her son were killed by an anti-tank
missile fired from Lebanon in in Yemen
houthis a group accused of terrorism and
war crimes that support Hamas vowed to
continue their attacks on shipping in
the redc David Aken Global News
Ottawa and later on in the newscast my
one-on-one conversation with Dr yaser
Khan he's a Canadian surgeon who tended
to patients within Gaza itself he's just
come back and he'll share his
experiences in Quebec police are
investigating the death of a 15-year-old
boy who fell from a ski lift on Friday
night the incident happened at a ski
resort 70 kilm Northwest of Montreal
where police were called in around 10
p.m. First Responders tried to
resuscitate the boy but he was
pronounced dead after being brought to
hospital investigators are looking into
the possible causes of his fall but they
believe no criminal elements are
involved it's already been days of
frigid conditions across this country
but Canadians from coast to coast to
coast remain in the grips of fierce
winter weather from dangerously cold
temperatures in the west and Storm
surges battering coasts in the East Hadi
petrac looks at how people are trying to
weather it the best they can as they
brace for
more the unrelenting extreme cold caused
pipes to burst at this long-term care
home in Su BC forcing residents to move
and this unusual scene in Vancouver a
flooded construction site turned into a
skating
rink next door in frigid Alberta we were
able to avoid having um any shutdowns
due to the lack of generation for the
system the province's Electric System
operator rescinded its grid alert last
night but asks residents to cut back on
consumption during peak hours the peak
period is always 4: to 7:00 p.m. that's
when power demands spikes shelter
workers in the Prairies are scrambling
to make room for the most vulnerable
facing lows ofus 55 with the windchill
our building is not big enough for the
number of people um across the board
everyone reporting well over a 100
people needing warming spots every day
in Eastern Canada cold and wind is
paired with some snow squall warnings in
Southern Ontario and blizzard warnings
in Northern Quebec the uh water is
starting to breach down here while in
the maritimes the second weather system
in less than a week brought more storm
surge this new brunswicker taking it in
firsthand and the wind gusts were they
were down around 5050 M an hour down
there and they were just slapping me
around with localized flooding again not
only in St Andrews but Yarmouth Nova
Scotia as well there's a danger there
and there's always the fear that someone
will go out and and get hurt but you
know so far so
good this picture will change with snow
in the maritime forecast Tuesday as the
rest of the country hopes for relief
from its deep chill Heidi pic Global
News
Halifax tens of millions of Americans
are under weather advisories with winter
storms hitting hardest from the Great
Lakes to the Pacific Northwest and an
Arctic blast causing hundreds of
thousands of people to lose power this
weekend and ferocious waves are wreaking
havoc in Maine heavy winds and rain have
triggered a record high tide flooding
roads and homes and even sweeping away
centuries old fishing
Shacks in Indonesia Mount moroi erupted
this morning spewing Ash more than 1 Kil
into the air no deaths have been
reported but officials have ordered
residents in the danger zone out to
avoid possible lava flows Mori is known
for sudden eruptions that are difficult
to predict like the one that killed 24
people while dozens of climbers were
ascending the volcano back in
December and for the second time in less
than a month a volcano erupted in
Southwestern Iceland and it sent lava
spewing toward the country's main
airport the eruption posed a threat to a
nearby fishing Town though it had been
evacuated earlier just as a
precaution opening Old Wounds to help
prevent a future tragedy coming up a
still grieving Saskatchewan First Nation
prepares for a mass killing inquest this
week and also coming up Denmark's new
king takes the throne as the country's
longest running Queen
abdicates
nearly a year and a half after 11 people
were killed in a series of stabbing
attacks in Saskatchewan a Coroner's
inquest is set to begin this week in
Melfort Saskatchewan most of the victims
were from the James Smith creen Nation
or Heather Yorks West joins us from now
Heather this week is expected to be very
difficult for the surviving victims and
the families who lost loved ones far in
the early morning hours of September 4th
2022 this community experienced
something so violent and horrific that
the lives of virtually every person
living here were forever changed now in
the coming days at a Coroner's inquest
the families of the 11 killed will have
to relive the events of that terrible
morning in graphic detail known
affectionately by his nickname chicken
Christian heads life ended far too soon
nearby Bonnie and Gregory Burns lay at
rest side by side mother and son three
of 11 lives lost to a horrific crime our
membership are 16 months past the
tragedy they've just started to open up
and move into the the beginning of of
the healing process the mass killings
here and in the nearby town of Welden
shocked the entire country triggering a
can can Ada a wide Manhunt after police
said the suspects mil Sanderson and his
brother Damian were still at large but
RCMP later revealed that Damian had been
a victim too miles Sanderson a Community
member with a long criminal history had
acted alone the PE system needs to be
fixed like uh miles was uh released he
was uh the First Nation wasn't given
notice like he was uh released without
you know fulfilling some of the
Rehabilitation needs that that they have
but why my Sanderson had been out on
parole will not be brought to light
during a Coroner's inquest in melfor
this week instead the hearings will
focus on the events leading up to the
deaths who died and where each person
was killed I can imagine our family
members and our band members that are
going to be going through a lot of
emotions in the next little while here
in advance of the inquest surviving
victims and family members scheduled to
speak at the hearing were privately
shown the evidence collected by the
coroner's office and the RCMP every
family that went through that process
left uh you know in in in tears because
it brought back that day of September
4th the inquest is scheduled to last at
least two weeks a second inquest will be
held into the death of the man accused
of these killings miles Sanderson died
in police custody shortly after he was
arrested far Heather York's West and
James SMI creation thank you
heather ah hand operating while the
building shakes our interview with a
Canadian surgeon who's just come home
from helping in
Gaza it has been 100 days since hamas's
October 7th attack on Israel and 100
days since Israel declared war on Hamas
and attacked Gaza with deadly force
since then it has been near impossible
for journalists and Aid workers to get
into The besieged Enclave but Dr yaser
Khan did and he joins me now he is one
of Canada's leading eye plastic surgeons
you left everything at the end of the
year and uh went to Gaza how did you
even get in well thank you for having me
um I basically flew from Toronto to
Cairo and then once I reached Cairo uh
we went through the Sinai desert through
at least eight checkpoints that took
about 8 n hours to the rougher border
which is the border between the Gaza
Strip and Egypt and each checkpoint was
checking our paperwork and things like
that and not just anybody can get in you
have to be approved by the Israeli
authorities the Egyptian authorities and
also the Ministry of Health and Gaza and
the World Health Organization so your
name is on every list and that's how you
get in what was it like to work in a
hospital in Gaza it was surreal because
around uh because first of all when he
stepped outside we had drones going
humming 24 hours so so you heard this
humming sound of drones 24 hours a day
there was bombs going every hour around
us about a kilometer away from us and
and they shook the whole Hospital
despite that you had to work because it
was a me it was I mean the sick and the
injured were coming every hour every
every time there's a bomb drop you get
about you know Ma about 10 20 mask
casualties coming in so it's constantly
moving what was the the most unexpected
thing that happened there when you were
there I think the most unexpected thing
for me was the amount of suffering I
actually did not anticipate even though
you know this is the first live streamed
Mass killing um you know I I think
that's it's it's
unprecedented but I didn't realize how
much suffering there is I mean and I was
taken aback by by how many people died
by how many people were injured and I
think what struck me the most was the
amount of people disabled I saw while I
was there I saw 15 to 17 amputations
alone myself I saw I I myself took about
8 or nine eyeballs out um I basically
you know people who are blind now I
fixed massive facial scars and I didn't
realize the extent of of suffering and
extent of disability these people are
going to be left with after you're
you're also a father of four besides
being a doctor how did that play into
what was happening and did you fear for
your
safety um I didn't fear for my safety I
was around dedicated healthcare workers
who are working and were calm despite
the bombs around them so we're all in
this together and there was a certain
camaraderie about saving lives together
which made me forget about my own safety
but worry about the safety of the people
I'm trying to save and so I didn't worry
about my safety and I mean as a father I
think um as a father of a six-year-old I
think that really struck me because I
saw one patient who came in with her eye
just blown out and I had to fix it and
she was six the same size as my daughter
and that's when I really broke down
because I thought that this child has
done nothing to deserve this and that's
a moment that really kind of got to me
yeah Israel uh has claimed for a while
now that Hamas Fighters are hiding um
underneath hospitals in hospitals or
near Hospital compounds you were at the
European Hospital in conun did you see
any evidence of that no not at all how
did you leave what was it like leaving
in that moment all these desperate
people behind honestly my heart is still
there my heart is with with the with my
patients that I saw my heart is with my
colleagues that I broke bread with every
night the local Palestinian doctors my
heart is with the 20,000 refugees that
are now Sheltering in the hospital and
my heart was is with all their suffering
and I actually didn't want to leave uh
the bombing was getting worse as as as
um as I was leaving but um I almost felt
guilty for leaving because there's so
much suffering there and there's so much
help that they need that it was hard to
leave I know you just came back a few
days ago but would you go back I would
go back in a heartbeat yeah Dr yaser
Khan thanks so much for sharing your
experience with us thank you for having
me next Denmark's new king and his
Australian born Queen how a surprise
abdication is charting a new course for
one of the oldest monarchies in the
[Music]
world as the New Year began Denmark's
longest serving Queen stunned her nation
and announced she was AB ating today her
son King Frederick VI 10th officially
ascended with much fanfare across
Denmark Nia galii looks at today's
celebrations it's history in the
making surrounded by
family and wiping away
tears Frederick the 10th is proclaimed
the new king of Denmark
forar
this after the surprise abdication of
his mother Queen Margaretta II the first
Denmark has seen in nearly 900 years the
fact that mcgr is actually passing the
throne on to her son while she's still
alive is is quite special closing out
her Reign that spanned 52 years the
83-year-old relinquished her crown in a
private ceremony Sunday Paving the way
for Frederick to take over that was
emotional because I'm 52 years old and
he's been a part of my life the whole
life you know and the way she has uh uh
performed it's outstanding I must say
tens of thousands of people converged on
the streets of Copenhagen near freezing
temperatures doing little to dampen the
celebration that's continuing late into
the
night it's a sign of the popularity
being enjoyed by the Danish
monarchy for many King Frederick and his
wife the new Queen Mary and 18-year-old
Crown Prince Christian represent the
ideal modern monarchy I think he's a
Down to Earth person uh feeling pry
relaxed he's more a king for the people
whereas M we all love her but she was
she was more cultivated probably and
more very Royal above people we are
excited now we have a king we've been
used to a queen n Gangi Global
News and that's going National for this
Sunday night I'm far Naser on behalf of
our whole crew here I want to thank you
so much for spending part of your Sunday
night with us tonight's your Canada is
lack St Louis in derval Quebec Donna
we'll be back with you tomorrow until
next time take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good
[Music]
night